hello and welcome to episode six of
Udacity talks a life series event where
we discuss topics with powerful thinkers
in Silicon Valley in the areas of
education careers and the hottest
technologies and take your questions
I'm Shiraz Dawber the chief marketing
officer at Udacity today we're doing
something a little different we're
flipping the script where Sebastian who
generally is the host is going to be
sitting in the guest chair and the
reason being you'd actually just
announced its self-driving car
nanodegree earlier this week and who
better to talk to you about self-driving
cars and answer hundreds of your
questions than Sebastian who is pretty
much regarded as the inventor or the
godfather of the self-driving car
Sebastian it's been quite a big week for
you you launched a nano degree you
already have over 4,000 applications
filled out for this program how are you
feeling it's crazy we expected a few
hundred do you have a few thousand no
it's going so fast it's amazing
why do you think this is happening I
think that's something in the air about
self-driving cars so five years ago when
I talked to people that's my team you
know said self-driving car same way when
I say flying car today people smile at
me and now it's become so real it's like
uber and others in this in this space
there are lots of young people just want
to work on self-driving cars and help
them shape up so what we do it doesn't
easily empower students to become stuff
driving cars we've got a ton of
questions when we put this news out
there and then questions coming from
Canada from the United States from India
and China so I'm just gonna dive into
them and let's see how far we can go in
30 minutes absolutely so from Phaedo
what originally gave you the idea of
creating a self-driving car I've been a
roboticist in my life in artificial
intelligence researcher as an academic
discipline and I care about that because
I felt big way to understand
intelligence and what better way to
instill interest in this building it's
yourself obviously I had car episodes in
my life some said I lost a good friend
in high school
but I really got engaged when dapper
launched a competition called DARPA
Grand Challenge in 2003
I was on my way from Carnegie Mellon
going to Stanford University when this
competition came along and I decided why
not why not just give it a try the very
first of those competition the best
driving car made about seven miles out
of 140 and I thought we could do better
than seven miles did you another
challenge after that yeah so the
challenge was repeated it was repeated
two years later 2005 and we won it we
had about a hundred 96 different teams
competing for this prize and my team was
lucky when they won it that's great so
here's another question from John Eric
what is your projected timeline for the
development and proliferation of these
self-driving cars and what do you
believe will be the major obstacles so
I'd say at this point is fair to say
that the technology is basically there
not every player has the for technology
but I've worked for many years at Google
and I believe Google technology is on
par or better than human right so it's
really more of a question of getting us
out in the field developing my business
models having the right legal framework
the beginning to do this and getting
customers involved and building up the
network or the brand and trust of people
in this new technology that's gonna
happen the next like maybe five years or
so there's a big race going on obviously
there's multiple business models there's
transportation service pair cars comes
at you like a taxi there's owner
operated cars there's aftermarket
businesses specialized things like truck
driving and Auto pursues so you have to
see which firm will be the fastest what
do you make of the uber news this week
it's great to see over in the in that
game we Nova has for a long time so as
for long time has told me that is really
afraid that a self-driving car could
destroy his existing business and he's
doing the right thing you three tries to
really get into the business understand
that he's had some phenomenal people you
just acquired a company called Auto
which is my former partner and student
and he never asked me and so when you're
partnering with an degree yes and
someone we're partnering with another we
as you deci that's great so now we have
a question from Z is it better to build
a self-driving car from zero or to
integrate self-driving technology into
current cars on the road
a little bit like Tesla's doing and why
so from zero I would not build a
physical new car if you really want to
make the car smart
what do you mean lose even have a place
to drive and let the car so you have to
worry about human eyes aka cameras human
hands aka actuators inside the car and
its really an artificial intelligence
endeavor
I think integrating the existing cars is
a good idea for into it because you just
buy a car you hack it a little bit and
then you can drive it automatically in
fact he does see we did this together
with a company called autonomous stuff
we got a car we bought that car that car
is ready for what's called drive for
wire so we have a little remote like a
video game we can go forward and
backward left and right and so on
through the turn signals and students
that take our new nano degree and sell
for the cars will be afforded the
possibility to actually run their
software on our car in real traffic so
you could be sitting in Sweden you could
sit in Bangladesh and all of a sudden
you're sort of a driver car in America
Wow so you kind of went to the next
question for which we've got about 50 of
the same questions is what does the
self-driving car nanodegree designed for
and will I get a job after yes we've
walked accompanies the one thing listed
publicly sapphires Mercedes nvidia diddy
and china and author of the solar
company and we basically went to them
and said hey there i guess you want to
start a curriculum where we raise
amazing people what do these people need
to know and then this companies have
very specific lists of things that
they're after
could be localization could be deep
learning it could be real time control
so we write all these things down and
then we ask the companies what I project
put proof proficiency and becoming self
again I'm very strong opinion sailor if
you can do the following type of a
situation you're going to hire the
person so that's what basic program has
become it's become a list of things of
skills and knowledge and students ought
to know to be proficient and
self-driving cars and our hiring
partners that we announced with
yesterday module eight two days ago they
actually sign the deal and said look we
gotta hire those people doesn't mean
there's no interview of course as an
individual decision to be made but they
are very willing to hire graduates from
our program as you go further I mean the
industry is large
not just heel sleeve Eliot's in Detroit
it's in Germany who stood guard many
other places so there's many many places
around the world where people are
gearing up it's not just the kinda
street it's the tech industry Intel and
video editor game by do so many
different companies you wouldn't think
of us car companies so all of those are
desperate to hire talent I think you can
easily place ten thousand people or more
in what time four in ten thousand people
if you had ten thousand well-trained
people right now I bet within three or
four months it would find jobs pretty
much although it's pretty impressive
yeah that's great so we have another
question from Schramm's
in India and I hope I'm pronouncing your
name right do you think that could be
self-driving cars in India where the
roads are not linear they're really
curvy and where the traffic flow is not
linear so I've spent time in India in
traffic and I've tried to understand
Indian traffic rules and I walked away
thinking it's different from America and
I've had seen instances where it seemed
that the bigger vehicle had the
right-of-way over the smaller vehicle
for the buses and the trucks first and
then the cars and then the viscous all
the way to the bicyclists there are
rules and what the self-driving car is
really good at is is precision
so the seventh car is an unbelievably
high precision in understanding where it
goes where other cars go and where they
can squeeze ooh we have not I have not
in my time at Google and that
terminology google has not launched
anything in India today and it would
take a substantial revision of the
software to deal with that kind of
traffic but I see no reason why not to
be honest so you think that self-driving
cars they see a cow coming out of just
out of the blue they will be able to
detect it and be able to yeah I mean
right now if you see a child coming out
of the blue running after a ball they
call let's talk to the child
cows are larger and actually easier to
find and they move slower at all most
parts so yes we believe that's dooba
again this is something we have to show
off right we have to be rebuilt
but I see no principled reason by a
place like India or Pakistan or Egypt
should be different than a sense days
it's great so one of the questions that
comes from Jordan is how do you kind of
deal with the ethical issues or the
self-driving car where you displace so
many people out of jobs because now the
cars going
drive themselves what happens to those
people I think I mean there's a general
question about progress we've made
enormous progress in the last hundred
fifty two hundred three hundred years
and in technology and automation and so
on and in doing so we've freed people of
certain types of work and empowered them
to take different types of work just to
remind us about 300 years ago we would
all have worked in the fields and the
defining we would go and plow every day
or make house every day over and over
again and the defining attitude of
humans was our physical strength and our
agility it wasn't our mind we won't
really trained to be thinkers we were
trying to be doers physically and yes
it's true that the agriculture evolution
and Philibert the distribution displace
a lot of work I think the outcome is
actually right desirable if you look at
it because now we have so much more
interesting jobs and we have so much
more interesting lives because of it we
don't have to do the same remedial
physical thing over and over again to
barely feed our family we have plenty
food in the world and we can become
playwrights become actors we can become
television anchors become engineers we
can become pilots all these things
didn't exist twelve years ago so I think
what's gonna happen here's the same
thing repetitive work like driving your
taxi at some point I think we're gonna
have amazing people who otherwise would
have been taxi drivers that become
inventors to become creators and we
empower them to do this and part of us
is mission of course is to teach those
wonderful people all these other skills
sometimes I hear you often talk about
self-driving cars not just affecting
transportation but transforming a ton of
industries and people have never
actually understood that or try to
figure out what it is could you share a
little bit of your thoughts over there
yeah so you know first of all the
automotive industry is a huge industry
specifically if you count all the
suppliers the supply internet industry
so if transportation as a service
becomes reality like the uber that comes
to you without a person side you
probably need a quad core off the Cosmi
after day on the streets that means it'd
be bad days for manufacturers to be
quite frank but other companies say
insurances insurances in United States
view car insurance has been sold to in a
car
as well there was profitable instruments
if insurance not have to do insure
providers entire companies they will be
able to negotiate company different
rates possibly companies are there
several short acts on the rental car
companies insurance for cars will go
away but other things like parking for
example right so right now if you build
an office building you have to supply
parking in the future you might not have
to
which means our offices would be closer
together and then we you utilize much
much better restaurants restaurants you
can make matter here just drop myself
off and the car goes away I would be
concerned if it was a parking garage
operator that might not last that long
that job but the nice thing is I'm
looking forward to the day when I come
to San Francisco and the streets are
free and there no part cars because
right now it's a nightmare most big
cities are full of parked cars what a
waste it's true I think somebody had
said mkq add that 60% of our space in
Los Angeles is devoted to parking
garages Carson general some roads
driveways and garages it's more than
half at 60% result an animus and not
always we go away man the streets will
stay but just image need a new garage
anymore
what do you think happens to people what
do they do in the cars do you think
about that well we lose in America we
lose about 52 minutes every day every
working day in car based traffic on
average there's our commute is a half an
hour commute in half hour commute out is
about the mean so that's time is lost
it's a lot of time in life if you walk
it out over a lifetime it's actually a
really a lot of time and it's like a
24th of the total time so if you live 24
years you lose one year right so if you
live 75 years he lost three years and in
cars now I want that time back
I mean I'd sleep I do homework I watch a
movie whatever I text safely and email
but I don't one is me the monkey in in
traffic congested traffic doing the same
steering and gas over and over again
having to pay attention here's a
question from Phil how big a role do you
think high accuracy GPS receivers will
play in the autonomous car industry they
already play an important role so we
have a GPS receiver on pretty much every
surviving car
and why did that tend not to use
differential GPS because in South have a
conversation they tend to use something
vast wide area network to really get for
two three four feet errors and but
Google did on top of it Google acquired
a map of the street and after the course
localization provided by GPS he does a
fine-grain additional localization just
by comparing the current sensor scan
with the previously recorded map and
those technologies are very important
Tesla doesn't do it Tesla doesn't have a
map and you can see when you drive a
Tesla that if there's a turn coming up
tester often doesn't know where turns
coming up and it's very late and might
the first I'm not slowed down for turn
but precision GPS you can actually
really give this cars and an elephant
memory and build a map of every single
Street and it allows you to do a lot of
safe stuff in advance they can store for
turns you know where the turn looks like
it turns invisible you still start
turning and so on kind of similar amy
has a question as just amazing
technologies being developed there is
still debate about using self-driving
cars and when an accident happens
who holds responsibility for that I
think there's precedent for this and
there's a fairly clear legislative
solution for for liability if the cause
of the accident is with the manufacturer
I would posit the manufacturer should
have liability if the cause is with the
operator then the operator should have
liability and sometimes is a little bit
mixed and I'm very much looking forward
to the assessment they would come out
with the most recent Tesla accident
where the first time the loss actually
being tested and the nice thing about
Sharon Carr says that they record a lot
of data so in our Google car you would
get in my new detail every motion of
everything around it and it makes it
really easy to determine whose fault it
was in the end much easier than
conventionally will be made an
eyewitness or not once all you have
so I see a time where trial lawyers will
have less work because because we'll
just have a very clear-cut decision
who's at fault so that industry gets
disrupted to the law industry I think
yeah anybody having to do with collision
like
collision repair trauma surgeons trial
lawyers if we do about drop bail then we
don't need them anymore to be honest at
least our four cars right a scary world
or a fascinating or it's a phenomenal
award I mean what what is good about
people young people old people having an
accident coming into a hospital and
having surgery I mean there's nothing
that I could describe that's good what
is good about when people have to argue
as a fault afterwards and spend lots of
money on lawyers I mean I love lawyers
but this is a great use of our societal
potential no I don't think so
so for me anything relieve accidents as
a negative wrap this is from our well
I'm a software engineer working in
Belgium I just got a PhD in wireless
sensor networks I'm wondering if I need
knowledge about mechanical engineering
to be able to craft a self-driving car
the answer is no I mean if you have it
it's good even friend with mechanical
skills is good but self-driving cars is
basically in a topic of artificial
intelligence it's video software show
the interface of the car is relatively
easy to build all you do is you snip a
few wires and you give signals into the
brake and sequences of the gas and
things on the steering and from that
point on excuse me it's all about
intelligence it's all about perception
bringing camera images interpretation
was in the images and then turning those
into control decisions so my Google team
in a Saturday we had I think in the
first year and a half 12 engineers none
of them are pension ears I'm Anthony
from Otto Anthony was the only person
who was halfway how to have engineers
correct and in relation to that question
do you think I need to have taken
specific courses before applying for
your Udacity self-driving car nano
degree so right now it's hard to get in
we have about 4,000 applications at this
point for 250 seats we want to extend
the number of seats but we said publicly
is that there's a prerequisite mm-hmm
you have to be able to code before the
incident like Python or C++ and you have
to have some good mathematical knowledge
algebra and statistics in particular and
that should be able to get you in more
to the fact that we have more
applications in your thoughts right now
will you what happened to the people
that don't get in what do you
recommend to them we will reopen that
later and that more students in you go
this program to thousands of students at
at times no question we're running it
small right now because it's the very
first iteration in Middle English well
it's great and we don't have too many
people being confused on something
Xanthia but it's big oh yeah that's
great
what were the successful students of a
self-driving car nanodegree look like in
10 years is one of the questions I hope
that successful students would come back
to us in 10 years
I hope they're going to get a wonderful
job at Mercedes or Google any of these
companies or builder and startup company
and after helping to advance the world
and make this technology mainstream they
might say now I want to work on drones
or on virtual reality or something else
and I hope you're going to come back to
us and remember that they got our
education from us there was a question
that kind of comes up is self-driving
cars only limited to the large companies
because we only hear about Google and
for in uber or can you have a start-up
in this area you can absolutely have a
start-up Auto is a good example
zooks is another example from a 1500
species student of mine Jesse Levinson
co-founded Zeus's and a 17 station
service company and there's many many
small companies sometimes the progress
and small companies is actually much
faster than a large companies so if
you're curious come out of Silicon
Valley visit some of the existing
companies and start your own one of the
questions comes up is I'm not in Silicon
Valley if I were to get a self-driving
car nanodegree what would I be able to
do in my country depends on what country
you live in
I mean North Korea is one thing but many
many countries have automotive
industries and build cars or car
components and even we have talked
recently to the king of Jordan about
self-driving cars even kind of either
have their own industry still have need
for engineers because they would wish to
deploy this kind of technology and
become a technology country further I
would say the skills that you will learn
in this analogy are broader than just
self-driving cars have to do with
estimation perception artificial
intelligence controls so any other
physical system like the robotic system
is very well covered another skill set
so the skill set is very broad and
I'd be shocked if you couldn't find a
good job with us so you walked into this
one but since you met with the king of
Jordan what did he say to you we had a
nice beautiful conversation about his
country and about the situation in the
Middle East
mm-hmm we had a few business
conversations I have myself a very
strong interest in bringing Udacity
education to the Middle East we already
have a refugee program in Germany for
Syrian refugees together with the BMW
foundation the Google we have about five
different classrooms in Egypt so one of
my goals but now as I see can be praying
more education of the police because
it's one of these regions where believe
there's amazingly inspiring people thing
and everybody's so disadvantaged when it
comes to education could they be able to
take a self-driving car nanodegree yeah
I mean it's happened to applicable laws
and subject to enhanced availability yes
another question from a student what is
the greatest challenge in achieving a
self-driving car if you were to guess
where will the solutions come from so
the biggest challenge is this this mean
little 1% of cases so making it drive 99
percent autonomously is easy 1% is hard
because it's the stuff that's really
rare and if this last 1% the very first
99 was still easy and then this last 1%
of 1% is hard and the the variety of
things you encounter are enormous at
some point I remember we had a plastic
bag blow of I across the highway and our
car went into deceleration because we
thought it was an obstacle he hadn't
told yet that plastic bags can fly in
the air across the highway of the size
if they were on the ground it could be a
massive rock so we had so many of those
situations we had strollers go crazy in
streets he had Diaz jump in front of us
things that are really hard to
anticipate and that's where driving
comes in and so reason why we drive
every day we get a lot of data and then
we can categorize the data and improve
the software was all of this happening
when you were at Google yes
what was the biggest surprise that came
for you when you were doing the
self-driving car project at Google well
the biggest surprise was that we could
do it I mean I didn't even very Page and
Sergey Brin brainstorming what we were
doing and they just said look Sebastian
why don't you just drive a thousand
miles and kind of
all hands off oh my god put this in and
not just any wise they said we gotta
find you my dad every hard like downtown
San Francisco and Bay Bridge and to and
back from knocked ro and we took a
coastal road from San Francisco to Los
Angeles like a nice little mountain road
another highway and and my take at the
time was that can't be done it just on
the DARPA Grand Challenge it heard of an
empty desert but not nothing and the
cost would be careening along and they
pushed me hard as it looks the best and
explain to me why it can't be done and
and I ran out of arguments almost like
yelling would say I'm the professor I
can say no it got damaged which of
course is meeting that you don't know it
and then I said okay why not let's just
give it a try and I learned an important
lesson I did see lessness if you don't
name how you don't show time maybe you
got to try these things almost every
expert who says it can't be done is
wrong in almost every field what was the
one disappointing thing out of the whole
project
I mean many as disappointing I wish I
mean I wish I had seen it too all the
way to launch I wish it would be
available today for public consumption I
mean Google has made enormous progress
in its technology and I think as I
believe is now more reliable than people
and we still long for the step and I can
actually use it as a normal citizen
every day after completing and Udacity
self-driving car nano degree do you
think someone could be able to make an
autonomous car just with easily
attainable off-the-shelf parts almost
like Lego yes absolutely yes but it
requires a certain skill set which is
what we don't teach us how to snip wires
in your Toyota Prius to actuates young
video on brakes and so on so you have to
build your interface to your car you're
not teaching this for safety reasons but
once you have control over those
components you should basically know
everything you need to know to bathe
yourself oh my god how long do you think
it would take in the hypothetical world
to just build a self-driving car after
getting this thing well funny you asked
we are doing an experiment right now we
have Udacity is own car you know and our
goal is to crowdsource new competitions
the very software components starting
actually next week to be honest
oh no the cover cleaning starts so we're
gonna put we already put on competition
our deep learning where students can
compete to predict what a human driver
would do in response to a scene and it's
a deep learning task we will be
designing more in the area of
localization of control and and object
tracking and predicting all the
essential things except an in-car the
Venus the competition we make some money
they're going to be invited to Mountain
View to hang off with me and other
people here and we hope I want to show
the world that we could actually
crowdsource a self-driving car I want to
get this car good enough we can drive to
San Francisco just based on a student's
work really really fast because we have
some amazing students and such strong
students it should be possible to
overtook OBD fast
that's great would that kind of beat
even the Google challenge that you had
with Larry well it took us a year and a
half to the Google challenge right we
picked ourselves one of the little legs
for the Google challenge internally to
drive which starts here at Mountain View
and goes to services : on a surface
street called a common area and if he
can do this the next challenge will be
deferred right exactly the same routes
to Google twelve five years ago with
crowdsourcing self-closing yes and
imagine this if you as a student
participant right
imagine you write the winning piece of
software right and it's really amazing
and Mercedes comes along and says you
were like that thesis off and say yeah
we happen to know the girl who wrote it
right give her a call she is Australia
you can hire her that's our goal we do
the Sillitoe for motor students you
don't do this because you want to be the
fifteen or twenty seven car company you
want to promote our students that would
be an amazing world absolutely here's
another question very base a complete
very interesting I'm a front-end web
developer can I use my background in the
self-driving cars field you can but I
think there's a different skill set that
you'll explore if you take or nanodegree
front-end this particular I think
concerned with design with speed with
level of cleanliness and if he goes into
issues of of user user design not just
programming and of course we all know
that the languages we used to program
web browsers are not exactly modern so
you have there were certain skills that
the D with very different kind of
mine in my opinion broken languages the
thing that's different in the
self-driving car feel is that you deal
with a view about data so you like
camera images coming in and you have to
write software that takes information
from those images almost the opposite of
a Vette front-end a front-end we have
information in your head when you convey
this to the user here information comes
in and you have to extract something
from it and that process of extraction
of information requires different
technologies so but the machine learning
is one probabilistic techniques that
there's another one so I would invite
you to join this one degree and learn
this different way of thinking because
no matter what you do afterwards you
have a much broader horizon with so many
companies now looking to create their
own self-driving car are they basically
using the same technology one of our
students asks there's a lot of overlap
and pretty much every company at some
point stops by my office and gets the
initial advice for me so I know a lot
what they do one of the big shifts
recently and last few years has been the
shift towards deep learning you might
all have heard about alphago beating the
world's best golf player you've probably
heard about our course and Udacity on
deep learning the Google bid with us
deep learning is this crazy idea that if
you just watch low enough and stare at
something long enough we eventually
surpass human intelligence and that's
new and that's really effective
companies like Nvidia our partner was
done seminal work Commodore AI auto
they're now all shifting towards deep
learning and away from more traditional
techniques so it could be this is one of
us fun questions with self-driving cars
getting safer than human driven cars do
you think eventually it'll be illegal to
manually drive I hope so I hope so I
mean if anyone finds it offensive then I
really recommend you go to your local
hospital in the trauma Department and
talk with the people who just came from
accident and might be dying
it is a privilege of pleasure to drive
don't get me wrong but the way we do
this we lose more than a million people
every year in traffic and I think it's
just unfair that we do this you have
something very lethal something very
they can kill people if the self every
car becomes was substantially safer we
should mandate the use of this
technology might
and there's precedent if you are pilot
I'm headed and say your commercial pilot
when you fly say a 737 and you have to
land the plane in bad weather you are
mandated to use the autopilot and a lot
of fly manual if you fly above 18,000
feet you are mandated to use all PI
you're not allowed to fly manual and the
reason is statistics shows that human
pilots have a much higher error rate in
auto pilots and to save the lives of the
people inside the plane the FAA has
decided to mandate the use of autopilot
do you think the US will be the first
country to do this or will there be
another country in the world that does
it it's this is up in the air I mean the
US has own shout set of challenges with
its own regulations and different states
have different challenges obviously
right now u.s. is very action is sec
more and see more work to be done China
and uncertainly in Germany which country
is the most friendly legal environment
is aankia
so a good example is Singapore recently
changed regulations and specifically
invited self-driving taxis in to
Singapore as a solution for the lies
last my problem of trains they might be
the first here's a question from Kieran
I passionately visualized the future
with all taxes being autonomously driven
in such a scenario which entity would
purchase the cars is there going to be
companies like uber or other taxi
companies and get it soon fantastic
question so generally in a world where
taxi fleets are self-driving you still
need taxi fleet management entities and
it could be overs on Google's it could
be independent companies that manage
those fleets or a mixture they off could
also be that people haven't cast their
own and they join the fleet instead of
parking the car when the cars not being
used one of those will succeed
most likely outcome will be that someone
like uber just buys lots and lots of
cars Stephan has a question how do you
see the self-driving cars technology in
case of emergencies will we ever see
self-driving ambulances or fire trucks
again I hope so that once this
technology is superior
and maybe an ambulance in the fire truck
are like 80% self-driving and 20% manual
driving doesn't have to be a hundred
percent but yeah I especially I mean if
you look at emergency vehicles it's a
really complicated task to drive them
well and drive them fast and I would
submit if you were to walk on this
they're at a point we would be able to
drive a emergency and more skilful
manner fast than most human I was good
almost like a plane yeah yeah what are
some of the learning models used in a
self-driving car for example how is the
lidar data and used in determining
position so these are two separate
questions and I'm gonna ask the second
one first lidar data is basically
produces a 3d point cloud around you in
the Google cover we develop and I ran
the team was a system to to cache a map
of the environment and then just do map
matching we would match the light of
skin to the map to get precision
localization that set of techniques is
well understood and has become basically
a hundred percent reliable never fails
and it gives us very precision
localization so you can know with like
five foot ten Sameach receiver the car
is which is very nice because we've also
stay in the lane you can almost blindly
stay in the lane at this point learning
all kinds of learning from deep learning
to parameter tuning beckoned ly good
grand challenge days we had this
ever-growing data of fire of of terrain
that had to be interpreted lasers but we
had some ground truth data and every
time there was something bad would feed
this bad data into our learning said and
and then overnight have it learned from
it and the next day we would take it out
and would be fixed we have modes for the
car and some human drivers like for
example when it comes to speed control
humans have a specific way to drive and
cars can watch humans and kind of
replicate the human driving behavior
that's phenomenally useful it's four-way
stop signs right before we stop signs
this is the us thing we have all these
there's someone who makes stop sign
cells has like I don't know link to
Congress because we have so many soft
signs we have like millions of subsets
in every city so they do it in four ways
and that the rule is whoever comes first
goes first we probe this in the
beginning and the car but wait and was
too
wait another two seconds just to be safe
and somebody else ran him off so you
just do what's what's because you've
been told you have no chance you're
never ever gonna call and the guy behind
you gets crazy so we ended up learning
the communication language so you
actually inch with your car into the
intersection in a specific way to
stipulate now is your turn
and whoever interests the fastest
asserts the highest priority and you can
try this out I mean try to do just for
the fun of it go first it's not your
turn and just assert yourself it's fun
you see this entire language unfolding
within this buddy it says moving with
some eye contact
that's interesting we have very little
time left so easy I see one quick
question do you believe automotive
companies will treat data as a
competitive asset or will they share it
I suspect most companies and London's
are sharing I suspect most companies
will be silos the only way you can see
sharing is either you have a monopolist
provider that has sunny others can't
afford like you could map data and there
I would submit our automotive companies
already sourced from companies like
enough taken others or you have the
legislature step in and mandate a
sharing layer and that's stupidly very
slow there's a lot of work on car to car
communication by the ideas cost talk to
each other and the legislature has been
trying to kind of build a system and
it's been unsuccessful so far in his
release but I could imagine at some
point of penetration second car is high
enough that there be some sort of
normalized let me I Triple E language
for car interchange that would inform
cars of each other and and have to make
more safe it's interesting let me end
this with asking your personal question
you have one transfer of interest tree
called self-driving cars that you're
considered the Godfather off you have
another one with education and Udacity
what do you want your legacy to be I
really every time a Udacity student
graduates and since we'd even say I
found in a job or something like this
that's that's my legacy I mean I don't
want a big legacy I just feel there's so
much good we can do in the world right I
mean all the people that in the future
might not be in a traffic accident
because a self-driving car technology
they never get to know me or where I did
this but this again
pick on the world I just am so enthused
to be in Silicon Valley and so intrigued
to really think about how to make the
world a better place if I can even save
one life or get one person in a great
inner job that's worth it
Thank You Sebastian it's been amazing
not even all the technology in just your
ideas about the world thanks so much for
joining us see us next time on series 7
of Udacity talks and in the meantime go
to Udacity and sign up for sebastian
self-driving car and nano degree program
thank you